there are over a billion people on earth
that don't have access to clean water
and you're complaining that your
instagram's not growing [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
just got to be thankful like people just
people just don't have perspective it's
really easy to be energized when you
actually understand the score
the problem is is that people just don't
have perspective right they don't
understand that it's impossible to be a
human being like it's impossible like
that's the rarest [ __ ] in the world and
so just people taking for granted you
know it's you're more likely to win the
lottery ten times than be alive
400 trillion to one that's how rare it
is to be a human being
everybody in this room is likely to get
by lightning seven times
more likely than being alive that's
crazy
perspective
and once you see gratitude and
opportunity life is fun you get to
decide if you're going to dwell and play
pre-event defense or if you're going to
see opportunity and be grateful
and go on offense
i'm inspired by practicality and reality
and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being i am one i have other good
things going for me as a human being and
i'm just grateful you you're dwelling
and looking at what you don't have
versus looking at what you have there's
nothing you'll ever accomplish that's
more remarkable than that you have a
chance to accomplish something when
you're so grateful for the at-bat
you're happy
but people dwell about dumb [ __ ]
what's something you think most people
take for granted
family time your health you know living
in america access to clean water food on
the table a roof over your head i'm
grateful for everything i have we lack
gratitude you understand that right i'm
trying to get people to practice
reframing their perspective i practice
gratitude every day
if i wake up in the morning and nobody i
love passed away or came down with a
terminal illness
then my day starts off great
if there was a list that ranked everyone
on earth in terms of overall success and
happiness from 1 to 7.7 billion where do
you think you'd rank and this is really
it for me this is really it if you
actually asked me why i'm so damn happy
all the time i play this game all the
time when i'm anxious when i'm upset
about something silly because i'm a
human
where do i rank
when they live in london
dubai
or los angeles you're living amongst the
wealthiest of the wealth and you're
looking in a very narrow window of like
well my neighbor has this but you
haven't taken it all the way up
and said look how grateful i should be
for what i have
i love when people are like easy for you
now no from the get
i cried when i got two star wars figures
instead of one when i was six because i
couldn't believe my parents could afford
to do that like i'm grateful i'm
grateful gratitude gratitude like
somebody's always got it worse
that's how i think about this you have
to stay grateful you can't take things
for granted we have so much abundance in
the world so much opportunity and too
many people are crying about what they
don't have instead of being so deeply
grateful for what they have
no really just stop right now take a
deep breath
[Music]
i'm not kidding take a deep breath do it
perspective
[Music]
you